Well, good morning church.
It's great to see you. What a privilege.
We have the freedom to be able
to do this on a Sunday morning.
We're so thankful for that.
Uh, my prayer has been that,
that your eyes would be lifted up above the chaos
of the world to see our true hope in our savior king.
I don't know what brought you here this morning,
but if you're new, we're so glad that you are here.
We'd love to help you get connected to our church.
There's a new here area in the lobby.
Just go say hi out there or,
or maybe you're, uh, may been here a few weeks,
you're kind of kicking the tires.
Like, is this where I want to plug in as a church?
Then we'd love to invite you next Sunday to
what we call next steps.
And it's a good place for you to get to know our church.
It runs every five weeks, so just kind of one through five,
one through five, one through five.
You can jump in at any point,
but it just helps you understand who we are as a church,
but also how to grow in your faith in really simple ways.
And so if you're looking for a next step,
that would be a great place for that.
Also, church, just briefly, I want to let you know that we
as elders are, are planning on starting a new elder class
to add some more pastors
to our council over the next couple of months.
We wanna start that process.
And so, uh, if you're a man who's feeling called towards
that and like, man, I just wanna explore that,
please come talk to one of us.
We'd love to explore that, kind of think through what
that looks like as we explore that together.
So I just wanna let you know, and you can be praying
for us in that, uh, today we are in week two
of our new series through the book of Second Samuel.
We're walking through this called the Promised King,
and God promised a king.
We found out that was David,
but also how David points us forward to the true
king Jesus Christ.
As we get into it today, I wanna tell you about my journey,
uh, that the Lord has taken me as a worshiper.
So early on I would characterize myself as a board
worshiper growing up in the church basically every Sunday my
whole fixation was on Elaine playing the pipe organ,
how she can play with both her hands
and her feet at the same time.
It's wild. That's all I wanted
to watch every Sunday until I got to college.
And then I would consider myself
what I would call an awakened worshiper newborn, uh,
where you're just kind of at the age
of 20, God will open my heart.
God brought me to himself and,
and it was just this sort of increasing awe and wonder, but,
but stumbling through it,
not really knowing much of anything.
What that quickly led to though was what I would term
an afraid of man worshiper,
where I got really quickly into this mode of thinking
and worrying about what you think about me
and worrying about what other people think about me and,
and struggling to obey in life
because I didn't want you not to like me.
And so then also just not expressive in worship.
I was kind of just stuck in in that sense
because I was really concerned about what others thought.
Now I'm not afraid of that anymore,
but here's the other ditch on that same road.
It used to be afraid of man,
but now it can turn into performing so
that you like me, which just by the way shows how,
how really sick our hearts actually are, if that's
how we play this from one to the other.
But gratefully, I can look back
and I can see how God has brought me down this road and,
and I think he's used three specific things to deepen
that lifestyle of worship in my heart.
First, God has used seasons of waiting
In my life that I've been forced to trust him
through things and wait on him.
It didn't happen right away, had to had to wait.
And so he's used that to shape my worship
and to trust him more.
That's first. He's also increased my awe just
through deepening my grasp of his holiness.
Like just understanding more of God as you read his word
and follow him like just overwhelmingly this sense
of stunned awe of who God is,
which has then led to a deeper awakening
to the joy of the gospel.
That if that's who God is, then this is who I am
and how far I am from him.
But look at what he has done, awakening joy in my heart.
And so God has combined all three of those things
to expand my worship,
to draw me towards obedience day to day
and to set me on a path toward loud singing
and loud living out there.
God has used all of that.
And so what we're gonna see today,
actually in two Samuel four
through six is David's journey in a similar way.
David's example, my prayer is that will move all of us down
that road towards worship.
He's gonna show us how critical it is for us to wait on God
to learn how to wait on God.
'cause here's the thing, we don't like waiting on God.
We don't like waiting for anything, let alone God
for extended periods of time waiting on him to come through.
We don't like it, but we have
to if we're gonna flourish in life.
But I think what we'll also see today is that many
of us have lost our awe of God
and we just kind of get bored with him.
And we're so casual in how we approach
the Lord of the universe.
We'll see it. And so I pray that God's word will hit reset
for us today in a lot of ways that it would prompt,
faithful, joyful worship in response.
Lord, we ask you to do that.
This is your word, it's not mine.
Speak through it Holy Spirit, apply it
to our hearts uniquely each one in this room.
It's very different. Apply it lead us in the way
of lasting in Jesus' name.
Amen. So take your copy of God's word, turn with me
to two Samuel four
and go through three chapters again.
So we'll just kind of bounce through it a little bit.
But we're gonna start in verse one of two Samuel four.
This is a bit of a recap kind
of catching us up in the story if you, if you miss it,
we're just walking through this whole book.
So if you miss a week, you can go back
and listen to that to make sure you stay up with the story.
But look at verse one, when ish Boche
Saal son heard that Abner had died at he, his courage failed
and all Israel was dismayed.
Now remember Israel Sheth was Saul's other son
who Abner had set up as king of Israel,
even though David was anointed King of Israel.
Abner said, no, Israel Sheth is, and
and he was in kind of contrast civil war like to David
reigning in Judah at Hebron.
And, and so there's this, this battle
that was set up because of that.
But then remember Abner defected to David and he came over
and, and Abner said, I'm with you David,
but David's general Joab didn't like that.
And so Joab killed
and so ish Bhe is feeling pretty alone at this point.
He's seeing the writing on the wall,
all these guys are leaving.
Things are tough.
And so I, I don't know, am I gonna make it or not?
Well The rest of chapter four is nearly identical
to the story that we saw last week with Saul.
If you remember Saul, there was a man
who thought he was gonna impress David.
So he goes and takes Saul out and comes back
and says, Hey David, I killed Saul.
And well David had him executed.
It's nearly an identical thing.
Two guys go and execute Ishbel Sheth, come back to David
and say, Hey David, I got your enemy.
Aren't you pleased? No,
he brought God's judgment on them in return.
But here's why all that's important.
Chapter four is getting us to chapter five.
Like as we move into chapter five, all that matters
because now the pathway is finally fully open
for David to step into the kingship of all
of God's people, not just Judah.
Now all of Israel
and even the people start to see this,
they start to acknowledge it.
Look at chapter five now verses one
and two,
then all the tribes of Israel came to David at he
and said, behold, we are your bone and flesh.
We are your family. In times past when Saul was king over
us, it was you David who led out and brought in Israel.
And the Lord said to you, you shall be shepherd
of my people Israel and you shall be prince over Israel.
Now that is something, if you remember, we saw God say
to David 20 years
earlier, right?
God anointed David as the king.
Even when Saul was still the king, David was anointed king.
And God said to David, you will be king over my people.
That was 20 years earlier
through all the wilderness though, all the trials,
all the exile, the caves,
the threats coming on David's life here,
it was finally fulfilled After all that time,
after all that journey, it was finally fulfilled.
The shepherd boy had become the shepherd king.
God's design is always perfect.
We're gonna put up that chart again.
This is the overview of two Samuel.
We'll use it most every week.
And so if you miss it, you'll be able
to catch it again some other time.
But, but here's what it's showing.
It's showing that we are just into that second phase where
God has moved David and the kingship
and the throne from Hebrew now to Jerusalem, seven
and a half years in He now 33 years in Jerusalem.
And that's important to know
because that was the place God had picked for his,
his temple, his place.
But it's not just that he moved David there.
What we start to see also, this is verse 10 of chapter five,
David became greater and greater for the Lord.
The God of hosts was with him.
The blessing of God on David again anointed 20 years
earlier, he's finally the king.
Now God is with him because his heart is for him.
And so now we see it finally come to pass.
Here's the point. The way David handled those
20 years shows us
that we are to worship.
As we wait on God.
Worship occurs as we wait.
It's not just we'll worship later, it's worship as we wait
patiently in the middle, it's worship.
Psalm 37, verse seven says, be still before the Lord
and wait patiently for him.
How hard is that though? Right? Our flesh
chafes at the slowness of God's clock.
Like we don't wanna wait for anything,
let alone wait 20 years
to fulfill the promise that God had made.
But notice something, the waiting, the 20 years
of waiting didn't make David bitter.
It made David better. It refined him.
And we watched his journey through one Samuel,
how God was refining him and testing him and growing him.
That was in preparation for this moment.
Maybe for you it's waiting on a spouse
where you know you, you gratefully haven't made it an idol.
You, you have a good desire, but you're still waiting.
Just ask the question, what is God
doing in your heart right now?
What Is he doing in you
to prepare you regardless of the end?
What is he doing in you right now?
Or maybe you're waiting on a resolution
to your health issues or to a, a relationship struggle
and it's just taken longer than you thought it
would and you can't get any answers.
And all this seven years waiting,
what's God doing in the middle of it?
Look to the Lord, worship him as you wait
or you're waiting on a job that aligns with your values.
You've had a couple opportunities,
but you think, man, those are unethical
and you're just waiting on God's right one to align with
what you are about
and you watch the savings dwindle in the process.
You're waiting. What do you do with that?
You look to the Lord, ask the question,
what is God doing in my heart?
What does he need to refine in me?
How is he working in me as I wait,
I'm gonna show you a video of a story
of someone in our church that has been worshiping
as they wait for something very specific.
Watch this.
I think during these periods of waiting, God has taught me
that he's trustworthy and that he's faithful.
Well, my name's Melissa Medo. Um, I'm married to Rob.
We've been married for 18 years.
Um, our kids are Annie who is 14, Ann Maddox is 12.
Well, like any parent, you want your child to know the Lord.
Any, like any Christian parent, I guess I should,
I should say you want your child to know the Lord.
And so, um, you know, you just kind
of wait, you see it happen.
Um, in kids who are younger,
you see it happen in kids who are older.
I always prayed for her salvation,
but I really started praying a lot in middle school.
I was like, Lord, please draw her to you.
And um, I caught myself.
I didn't realize that at the time,
but I was kind of trying to manipulate things
and do them for her, which sounds really silly, I know.
Um, but I, you know, would think, oh, if I can just get her
to go to this student event
or get her to hang out with these people, then maybe that's,
maybe then she'll know she needs Jesus.
It was just my mom mind working overtime, trying like,
'cause I know everyone needs the Lord.
And one day in the fall of 2023,
the Lord very clearly told me, stop striving.
I've got her. And I thought, okay,
Lord, was that really you?
He first told me through the Holy Spirit
and then in the following weeks he used three different
lectures by three different teachers.
They all used the word striving in their lectures.
And so I was like, okay Lord, I hear you.
And so that was a promise I knew that he made to me.
And I just had to hang on to that promise
because there were some um, there was a lot of dark days.
I kept having to tell myself, it's not my responsibility,
it's my responsibility to model things for her,
to talk about the Lord, to bring her to church,
but I can't save her.
When we picked her up at Canac Cook this summer, um,
we are always anticipating a big work
by God while she's at camp.
And she was more talkative, more happy to see us.
Um, definitely just had kind of a peace about her.
And so I enjoyed that thinking. Oh, she softened a little.
So we picked her up on a Friday, that following Sunday
after church, she came out with a group,
group of friends crying.
And she told me that she had accepted
Christ at Canuck at a night they call crosstalk.
And I just had immediate tears.
We were in the midst of a really difficult summer.
And hearing that she finally had come
to salvation was such a relief and such a gift.
And this whole time he was working behind the scenes.
I mean, I was like, yes, Lord,
a a promise fulfilled like here it is.
I've been waiting. I've been hanging onto your
promise that you've got her.
And here it is. I think during these periods of waiting,
God has taught me that he's trustworthy
and that he's faithful.
And that even though I don't understand
why things aren't being done in my time,
which is a big theme of my entire life,
I always want everything done when I want it done
and not waiting for God.
But it's always worth it.
I cannot imagine any other way for my daughter have to come
to salvation than during this time in the summer
whenever I was struggling and sad
and just, you know, all of these things.
And I get this gift of my daughter accepting Christ
in the middle of a really,
really hard season worth the wait every time.
His timing is perfect.
That may be your story could be something very different,
maybe infertility, maybe it's family struggles.
I don't know what it is. But listen,
you're not the first one to have had to wait.
You could even go back to Jesus spent 30 years in obscurity
before God said, okay, now it's time.
Father said, now it's time.
But what happened even immediately
as he walks into the ministry 40 days,
he goes out in the wilderness
and he has to wait fasting through no food, no water,
tempted by Satan the whole time proving
his faithfulness in his humanity.
He was showing that.
But he had to wait through that,
which led to Hebrews five saying this, in the days
of his flesh, Jesus offered up prayers
and supplications with loud cries
and tears to him who was able to save him from death.
And he was heard because of his reverence.
Although he was a son, he learned obedience through
what he suffered and being made perfect,
he became the source of eternal salvation
to all who obey him.
Now, Jesus was always perfect,
but what this is saying is that his saving role for us
was proven as he waited through
and overcame the enemy's temptations through his suffering.
He said, I am worthy. I am the Savior.
And so worship as you wait, worship
as you wait, his delays are not his denials.
His timing is perfect.
He will always be with his children through whatever it is.
And you can trust that he's growing your christlikeness
through it no matter what you wait for.
Now here's what happens though.
When we are in that struggle,
the temptation shows up for us to say,
okay, I'm in the middle of the waiting.
I'm in the struggle. I just gotta make it.
And you get kind of tunnel vision on making it
through the problem or the waiting game, whatever it is,
and you kind of abandon and, and really devalue
and think less of God and set him on the shelf
or leave him behind because
you're just like, I just gotta make it.
This waiting is hard. I just gotta make it.
And so we get flippant in our treatment of God
because we're so focused on ourselves.
Well here's why two Samuel chapter six is really
important for us.
It paints a picture of God that we must not trifle with.
We must not set on the shelf, we cannot leave behind.
Look at verses one through four of chapter six.
David again gathered all the chosen men of Israel, 30,000.
And David arose and went with all the people who were
with him from Baal Judah to bring up from there the Ark
of God, which is called by the name of the Lord of hosts
who sits enthroned on the cherub.
And they carried the Ark of God on a new cart
and brought it outta the house
of Aine Daab, which was on the hill.
And Za and Ohio, the sons of Abada were driving the new cart
with the arc of God.
And Ohio went before the arc.
Now this is the same arc of God
that we saw in one Samuel, right?
Remember that it's the same arc that Harrison Ford was
looking for, probably, I don't know, maybe not.
But um, seriously though this, this was
the symbol of God's presence with his people.
It was where they would meet with God.
The the high priest would go in to the holy
of Holies once a year with the atonement, blood sprinkled
sacrificial system to say, to forgive their sins.
All of that, that was the presence of God was illustrated
by this arc.
Now as we see this process happen in chapter six,
right away we see something that's off
This cart was not the prescribed way God had for them
to transport the ark when they needed to.
Very clearly back in Exodus it was supposed to be Levites
using specific poles through the rings on the Ark
of the Covenant, the priests carrying it by hand.
And so here's a difference right now.
Now here David's heart was right.
He wanted the presence of God with him in Jerusalem,
but his method was wrong.
Just as a side note, good intentions,
never excuse disobedience to God's clear commands.
But I wanted to do, I meant to no
do it the way God says to do it
because here's what happened next, watch this.
It's pretty shocking. Verses five through seven
and David and all the house of Israel were celebrating
before the Lord with songs liars, harps, tambourines,
castane, net symbols.
And when they came to the threshing floor of naan,
za put out his hand to the Ark of God, took hold of it
for the oxen stumbled
and the anger of the Lord was kindled against Za.
And God struck him down there because of his error.
And he died there beside the Ark of God.
It's pretty stunning, isn't it?
God's direct command back in Exodus, nobody touched the box
like that was abundantly clear.
Nobody was to touch the Ark of the Covenant.
But but you have to put yourself in this shoes, right?
Like USA it seems noble,
the oxen stumble the cart kind of hits a bump or something
and it looks like the arc of the covenant is gonna fall off.
And so he puts his hands up to stop it
from falling on the ground
and he ends up dying on the spot.
Well, what he did wasn't noble,
it was actually presumptuous.
It was a lack of trust in God's sovereignty
that God could handle the arc of God himself.
He's in control of everything that was happening.
Za says, no, no, I've got to take control here.
It looks like it's about to go this way.
I need to pull this back.
And in this USA's death was a sign
that God's holiness cannot be trifled with.
It Must not be handled flippantly.
Watch David's response in verse eight.
And David was angry
because the Lord had broken out against za.
Now that's, that's a valid response, right?
He's asking questions, God, what are you doing?
He, he's questioning the whole thing here.
And so he's angry
and yet at the same time we see fear, we see
reverence for God.
Look at verses nine through 11.
And David was afraid of the Lord that day
and he said, how can the ark of the Lord come to me?
And so David was not willing to take the ark
of the Lord into the city of David,
but David took it aside to the house of Obed, Edam, the Tite
and the ark of the Lord remained in the house of Obed,
Edam the Tite for three months.
And the Lord blessed Obed, Edam
and all his household again, just the power of God
by its very presence, brought blessing on that household.
It shows something there.
But, but I want you to think about
what David would've been doing in those three months.
The arc of God that he was intending to bring home
now is sitting in somebody's barn.
And what is David reflecting on? What just happened?
He's for three months reflecting on the holiness of God
that he saw one of his brothers right next
to the Ark of God die because he touched it.
He has to reflect. And what was God doing?
God was drawing his heart towards deeper reverence
that David would've grown in this awe
and wonder, which is the the point here
as you and I revere God, we grow in worship
as we grow in this reverence, in this awe,
this stunned reality
before a holy God that will grow our worship.
You saw that word afraid.
Show up if you do a study through the Bible dozens
of times this phrase fear of God or fear of the Lord.
Some form of that show up in the Bible.
Now today for us we tend to think of the word fear
and we think of being afraid of something,
being terrified of something.
And there is an element of that in this, right?
This guy was on the spot judged if,
if God could take you out on the spot,
there should be a bit of fear there.
There should be a measure of healthy like I am not God.
He is and I should be concerned in some way about that.
But mainly that word fear in the Bible is used with a sense
of respect and awe wonder at
who God is at His power that you're just stunned by God.
That word is reverence.
That there's times where you would just go
utterly silent before the Lord.
It's like Isaiah six, he got a vision of God on his throne
and his face went on the ground and he just said, woe is me.
I'm a man of unclean lips.
I'm among a people of unclean lips.
I can't stand before God.
That's what we're talking about, reverence.
I was trying to think of a good way to illustrate this.
It's, it's not a great illustration,
but kids, you know what it feels like
whenever a huge dog walks up
to sniff you in the face, right?
Like it's terrifying and cool at the same time.
Like you, you want the dog to like you
but you also don't want the dog to hurt you
and you're kinda respecting it but you love it.
And all this, it's like this weird dynamic of fear mixed
with a a desire.
It's kind of like the fear here.
It is not a perfect
illustration, but it's kind of like that.
And so let's think about this from two Samuel six,
what just happened here with USA and the cart and the arc?
Like what just happened here? Let's think about this.
If this is who God is,
if this, if this is who God is, we are so casual
in approaching his throne, right man,
we just go with it like, like flippantly.
Now we, I'm not saying we don't come boldly
before the throne by the blood of Christ.
Yes we can come boldly, but we should never come carelessly
because the same God who welcomes us in His grace
is the same God whose holiness consumed usa.
It's not different gods,
it's not an Old Testament God, a New Testament God.
This is the one true God all over it. That's the same God.
We serve a God of both mercy and majesty.
Remember that when you're sitting alone at your computer
tonight,
think about that when you're deciding whether to go
to the bar Friday night or not,
walk in this room
With A renewed sense of expectation that you're meeting
with the God of the universe.
Like can you just imagine if Jesus was sitting right here,
how this whole thing would
change, how would we be different?
How would it be different if Jesus is sitting next to you
as you're on your computer tonight,
how would it be different as you're walking
through school the hallways and Jesus is walking with you?
How would your words change your actions,
change your thoughts, change.
He is there with you.
He is here with us.
He is enthroned right now sitting right here
receiving our worship.
And so should that change anything about us?
And here I'm not trying to scare you.
We have to understand His holiness.
If we're going to appreciate his grace,
like to get this picture of him and his holiness
and we are so far from that we are deserving of nothing
but judgment like usa.
We deserve that.
And yet yet,
he looked at us and said, no, no,
I want you to be a part of my family.
Pay for you with my son's life like that.
That should spark something in us, right?
And I want you to watch how David responded next.
He, he processed the three months he thought through it,
watch what he does next.
Verse 12. And it was told King David,
the Lord is blessed the household of obit edem
and all that belongs to him because the ark of God is there.
And so David went and brought up the Ark
of God from the house of Obed Edem to the city of David
with rejoicing.
And when those who bore the ark
of the Lord had gone six steps, he sacrificed an ox
and a fatten animal.
And we assume every six steps that would've happened.
And David danced before the Lord with all his might.
And David was wearing a linen ephod.
So David and all the house of Israel brought up the ark
of the Lord was shouting and with the sound of the horn,
see now they're doing it God's way.
Like the priests we're carrying it.
Now they're sacrificing in light of God's holiness.
They understand it now. And so they're like, God,
we don't wanna do anything wrong here.
We're gonna sacrifice, we're gonna sacrifice,
we're gonna carry it like you told us to.
All of that is happening right here.
And look what it unleashed.
You see David dancing and people celebrating.
Here's the problem though, not
everybody was excited about this.
It, It seems like it,
but David's wife McCall, that was Saul's daughter.
Remember they got married in one Samuel.
She was offended at the way David
responded to the Ark's return.
In fact of verse 16 says, she despised him in her heart,
Despised him for his response.
'cause here's what she thought. She thought he went too far
and he stripped down to his linen eod,
which was basically the undershirt under their robes.
That was essentially that.
And and he, he did that
and he would dance and all of these things.
And so she thought Pridefully, she was focused on his image,
his role, his status
before the people like David, you went too far, man,
you should not have done that
because they're not gonna respect you anymore.
They're not gonna follow you anymore.
This is going to hurt your influence.
Here's how David responded. Look at verses 21 and 22.
And David said to McCall, it was
before the Lord who chose me
above your father and above all his house, to appoint me
as prince or leader over Israel, the people of the Lord.
And I will celebrate before the Lord.
I will make myself yet more contemptible.
Some translations, I'll make myself undignified
and I'll be a base in your eyes.
But by the female servants of whom you have spoken by them,
I shall be held in honor.
He's saying I'm gonna be even more undignified.
And I know you don't like it, but you know what?
Those people will respect it because they understand grace.
What you're seeing here is David's humility, right?
He understood what grace of God he gave me
to choose me to be the king.
Really? How could I not celebrate?
How could I not give praise to this one who chose me out
of all of Israel, my little family, I was the weakest.
He chose me. How could I not celebrate McCall?
I don't care what you think.
He wasn't worried about what McCall thought.
He was more concerned about what God thought of him,
even at the cost of his own reputation.
He said, no, I'll be more undignified
because he is worth it.
Galatians one 10 says this, I am now.
Am I now seeking the approval of man or of God?
If I were still trying to please man,
I would not be a servant of Christ.
I think you see where this is going, right?
We must worship as we rejoice
in our God as well.
He said he brought it back with rejoicing.
He's showing rejoicing.
He's dancing, he's celebrating their, their loud music.
All of the things. There's celebration happening.
We must worship as we rejoice as well.
'cause we have so much that we can give praise to God for
Is grace to us Joy-filled praise in response.
And listen, I'm not saying life is not hard.
I know life is difficult for you and and many in this room.
This last week has been hard for many people.
We'll talk a bit more about that later.
But listen to Nehemiah eight 10, the joy
of the Lord is my strength.
And Nehemiah said that when Israel was a train wreck,
they came back to the land.
They have to rebuild the walls. It's in shambles.
But they recognized God's grace in all of it,
his goodness to them.
And so he could say, the joy of the Lord is my strength.
And they were able to have joy in the midst of hardship.
Is that the kind of worshiper that you are?
Are you able to worship in the midst of hardship?
Are you able to respond like David did?
Undignified, willing to be that in response
to God's glory and grace in your life?
Are you ashamed like McCall Paul,
worried about what other people think?
Are you this kind of worshiper?
Now here's, here's what I, I don't want you to hear.
I'm not saying that in response to this.
You all gotta roll around on the aisles and run laps
and worship like that's not what I'm saying about this.
Okay,
But why?
Just ask yourself, why am I ashamed
to worship my savior king?
Why am I ashamed to speak up
and say I'm a Christian?
Why am I scared of that?
Like shouldn't it spark joy when we remember
that the only reason that we who are unholy
can rejoice in a holy God is
because of all that Jesus has done for us?
Like shouldn't that spark something in us that we see
how far from him we actually are.
And then he looked at us, his enemies
and said, I'm gonna pay for you
to be in my family with my son's life.
Come on, be with me for you don't deserve it.
You deserve judgment. I'm bringing you into my family and
and we see how stunned we should be by that.
Should that not spark joy, the praise of God,
the joy filled explosion of just wonder
he took the judgment we deserve so
that we could come boldly to his throne of grace,
not carelessly, but boldly to his throne.
How much more should we worship because of that truth?
And listen sometimes. Sometimes that's gonna have to happen
as you wait through the 20 years of the wilderness.
And you're gonna have to look at him
and say, okay, Jesus, you're worth it.
I don't know if or when you will, but you're worth it.
I'm gonna worship as I wait. What a testimony that is.
And sometimes that worship is not gonna be loud, explosive.
It's gonna be you deeply impacted by the
holiness of God to where you're on your face before him
and you can't even lift your eyes
because you're so overwhelmed by the glory
of God reminding you of your depravity
and how far you are from him.
That's then a response of worship to say, God,
you are who you say you are.
But all of that should lead us to more joy
and more exuberant praise
for the God who's done everything necessary for us
to be in relationship with him forever.
We are more than willing to raise our hands and sing loud
and shout loudly when our football team wins.
And yet we look bored
and we're scared of what people think about us
when we're saying to Jesus, you are God, you are my savior.
I don't deserve it. Praise you forever.
I just wanna invite our worship team out
and I want us to go ahead and begin
to stand up if you're able,
because what we need to do is respond.
And here's what that means today.
It might mean that you don't stand up
and your response is just to get on your face
before God Because you're in
a season of waiting or,
or you're in a season of like, I,
I've flippantly handled this thing with God
and I don't see him as who he is.
And maybe that means on your face, maybe that means
for the first time you kind of tune out,
there's a, there's a corporate side of worship
that we are encouraging each other, but,
but for the first time, you're not thinking about
what everybody, everybody else is thinking about you.
You're thinking about what God thinks
and responding to him in worship to
where you sing hallelujah, which simply means,
praise our God.
And you sing that boldly, loudly for the first time.
Or maybe you're just like, I don't know anything about this.
I'm struggling with this whole thing about who God is.
There's men and women along the sides of this room
that just right now you, you step outta your seat
and you go talk to them and say, Hey, I don't know
that God been in church my whole life.
I don't know what he's talking about. Can you help me?
Or I pray for this and we'd love to pray for you for that.
There's no shame in walking towards those people
and saying, Hey, I need some help.
Why would we be ashamed? This is what we do here.
And worship is what we do. Worship out there is what we do.
That's life. And so let's respond to him
as we wait hard season of life.
Let's wait and worship in response.